The Legend of Zelda has had many heroes
over the years from the hero of the
skies to the hero of winds to the hero
of the wild each of these heroes is a
boy named Linc who has defied all odds
and expectations and saved the world of
the goddesses from the clutches of evil
but though each link has their fair
share of heroic deeds one in particular
stands out head and shoulders above the
rest of them and I mean that somewhat
literally this iconic hero among heroes
is the one and only hero of time from
the games Ocarina of Time Majora's Mask
oh yeah and Twilight Princess for those
who have played the games we know of the
hero of time lived on after his
adventures in Ocarina of Time and
Majora's Mask and the next time we see
our beloved ocarina player he's dead
he's a ghost that can't move on into the
next world and lingers on in our own
world because he has unfinished business
which according to his own words is
because he quote could not convey the
lessons of that life to those who came
after end quote by the end of Twilight
Princess
he's eased his regrets and moved on but
here's where it gets interesting if the
hero of Twilight is x descendant that
must have meant that the hero of time
had children of his own blood in later
years if he wasn't able to teach his own
children the lessons he needed to teach
the hero of Twilight does that mean that
he died unexpectedly does this mean that
something killed him
now I know what you're thinking what if
he died of natural causes what in the
world would have been able to kill the
hero who defeated the demon king Ganon
as a ten year old boy in a seventeen
year olds body good questions let's talk
about him
first off let's expound on what we know
to be factual about the hero shade so
that we're all on the same page as
previously mentioned according to the
Hyrule historia and in-game dialogue the
hero shade is Ling from ocarina of time
another piece of evidence proving he's
the ghost of the hero is that he also
has a wolf form just like the hero of
Twilight does and his song selection for
the howling stone segments are nearly
all songs from Ocarina of Time or
Majora's Mask both of which are
Adventures of the hero of time
furthermore we know that the shade is an
ancestor to at least the hero of
Twilight because of the in-game piece of
dialogue where he mentions the hero of
Twilight is carrying the hero's
bloodline and he's hell bound on
teaching his secrets to the next
generation the hero of Twilight after
he's done teaching the hero of Twilight
all of his super secret samurai sword
skills he states that he has at last
eased his regrets before uttering his
final farewell but once we begin looking
at the visual clues we can get from the
shades appearance questions begin to
start popping up most obviously the hero
shade is fully clad in armor now while
this could be personal armor he had
whipped up for himself later on in life
I tend to think that it's Knightly armor
if you look closely at the more raggedy
portions you can see the armor included
a layer of chain mail which has been
either pierced or rotted away and
chainmail is not only a historical
staple of Knightly armor but is worn by
all the Hylian soldiers in Twilight
Princess the helmet is also rather showy
which was typical in historical times as
a show of rank for example Roman
centurions who outranked regular
soldiers would wear these really floofy
things on their heads as a sign of their
rank and authority you don't see any
personal armor sets looking that showy
throughout history unless of course
we're talking about Skyrim his armor
does have markings on it but no matter
how much
I can't link the designs to any people
group across the zelda franchise if you
think you know something about the
markings on his armor please feel free
to let me know in the comments below now
let's look at the state of his overall
of self the fact that the body we can
see fades in and out of visibility means
he's some sort of Specter or ghost and
not a stalfos which is a physical
skeletal enemy though yes he does bear
some visual similarities his armor is
old cracked and rotted but more
importantly it's battle-hardened we can
see that one of his helmets horns is cut
off not worn or rotted but cleanly
sliced off indicating battle against
sword users or maybe a nasty beast with
really sharp claws oh yeah and he's also
missing an eye there doesn't appear to
be a scar on his face surrounding his
eye meaning and I apologize if this is a
little gross but this most likely means
that his eye got damaged by something
piercing it and then it had to be
removed finally we see that he doesn't
exactly look like he's been buried I
mean do you see what he's covered in
leaves lots of leaves I mean correct me
if I'm wrong but I don't think leaves
tend to sprout around and grow when
they're six feet under no this guy is
dead and isn't buried and it's from this
that I deduce he died out in the field
fully clad in battle and his body was
most likely never found this would
explain why he's a regretful ghost now
he was taken from this world before he
wanted to be he didn't get to say
goodbye to his children or his wife
sounds like a classic vengeful ghost
story to me so now that we're all on the
same page with what must have happened
to the hero of time it's time for the
big question who or what did this to the
hero we have a few clues one he was
killed in an area that would probably
support lush greenery as we see vines
growing on his armor to the killing blow
was most likely delivered to his abdomen
as that's the only part of his armor
that appears to be completely destroyed
and would therefore mean he was most
likely dealt a killing blow that would
look something like well
which means his attacker was most likely
a blade wielding foe this is all
complete speculation of course but here
are two of my guesses one he may have
been in the Lost Woods when a stalfos
got the better of him maybe multiple
stealth oohs maybe they outnumbered him
and after all those years of the hero
being triumphant over the skeletal
enemies they finally overpowered him and
he paid the price with his life another
really interesting idea is that his old
foe Dark Link himself caught back up
with him but this time Dark Link was
victorious it's important to note that
we don't see Dark Link die in the water
temple after we battle him he just kind
of fades away the same as he had been
doing throughout their whole battle
anyway we do see references to Dark Link
in Twilight Princess so if the entity
was still alive between the events of
Ocarina of Time and Twilight Princess
I think it's probable that link crossed
paths with his old foe again what if
link met with him in the lost woods
where he's from to finish what was
started long ago and truly defeat the
darkness within himself only this time
without the Master Sword he met his
ultimate demise you gotta admit it's
incredibly poetic but also just a theory
a Zelda theory I have no idea where I
got that from what do you think was the
hero of time killed did he pass away of
old age tell me all about it in the
comments below and if you liked this
video please be sure to leave a like to
help the channel out also if you haven't
subscribed yet subscribe right now for
much more zelda content to come check
out my other theories and top 10s I've
done about Zelda on the channel I pulled
you guys again a few days ago about the
title of this video and again we had a
winner the person with the username ran
in my discord server got it almost right
off the bat so ran congratulations leave
us a comment below if you want to
proclaim your victory to everybody else
watching and to everybody else watching
if you'd like to get a shout out just
like this one be sure to stay tuned for
my next tip that'll be coming out in
about a week if you guess it right
you'll get a shout out as always huge
thanks to you for watching and to my
beloved patreon supporters for doing
what they do and making my day every day
check the links in the description for
my discord server to chat it up with the
best of us or to check out my patreon
support
and get your name in every one of my
videos that's all I've got for you today
so without further ado this is master
tena bandits signing out peace
[Music]